but we have drawn over here is five
different triangles and what I want to
do in this video is figure out which of
these triangles are congruent to which
other of these triangles and to figure
that out I'm just over here going to
write our our triangle congruence
postulate so we know that two triangles
are congruent if all of their sides are
the same so side side side we also know
they are congruent if we have a side and
then an angle between the sides and then
another side that is congruent so side
angle side if we reverse the angles on
the sides we know that's also a
congruence postulate so if we have an
angle and then another angle and then
the side in between them is is congruent
then we also have two congruent
triangles and then finally if we have an
angle and then another angle and then
aside then that is also any of these
imply congruence so let's see or
congruent to triangle so let's see what
we can figure out right over here for
these triangles so right in this
triangle ABC or over here we're given
this length seven then 60 degrees and
then forty degrees or another way to
think about it we're given an angle an
angle and a side 40 degrees in 60
degrees then seven and in order for
something to be congruent here they
would have to have an angle angle side
given at least unless we maybe we have
to figure it out some other way but I'm
guessing for this problem they'll just
already give us the angle so they'll
have to have an angle an angle side and
it can't just be any angle angle inside
it has to be forty sixty and seven and
it has to be in the same order it can't
be 60 and then 40 and then seven if the
forty degree side has if one of its side
has the length seven then that is not
the same thing here here the 60-degree
side has length seven so let's see if
any of these other triangles have this
kind of forty sixty degrees and then the
seven right over here so this has the
forty degrees in the sixty degrees but
the seven is in between them so this
looks like it might be congruent to some
other triangle maybe closer or something
like angle side angle because they have
an angle side angle so it wouldn't be
that one this one looks interesting this
is also angle side angle so maybe these
are congruent but we'll check back on
that we're still focused on this one
right over here and this one we have a
sixty degrees then a forty degrees and a
seven this is tempting we have an angle
an angle
and a side but the angles are in a
different order here it's 40 67 here
it's 60 47 so it's an angle and angle
inside but the side is not on the on the
40 degree on the 60 degree angle it's on
the 40 degree angle over here so this
doesn't look right either here we have
40 degrees 60 degrees and then 7 so this
is looking pretty good we have this side
right over here is congruent to this
side right over here then you have your
you have your 60-degree angle right over
here 60-degree angle over here it's a
little it might not be obvious because
it's flipped and they've they're drawn a
little bit different we should never
assume that just the drawing tells you
what's going on and then finally you
have your 40 degree angle here which is
your 40 degree angle here so we can say
we can write down that and I'll do it
let me think of a good place to do it
I'll write it right over here we can
write down the triangle a b c is
congruent to triangle now we have to be
very careful with how we name this we
have to make sure that we have the
corresponding the corresponding vertices
map up together so for example we
started this triangle at vertex a so
point a right over here that's where we
have the 60 degree angle that's the
vertex of the 60 degree angle so the
vertex of the 60 degree angle over here
is point n so I'm going to go to N and
then we went from A to B B was the side
was the vertex that we did not have any
angle for and we could figure it out if
these two guys add up to 100 then this
is going to be the 80 degree angle so
over here the a degree angle is going to
be M the one that we don't have any
label for it's kind of the other side
it's the thing that shares the 7 the 7
length side right over here so then we
want to go to n then M and then finish
up sorry n m and M and then finish up
the triangle oh no and I want to really
stress this that we have to make sure we
get the order of these right because
then we're kind of referring to we're
not showing the corresponding vertices
in each triangle now we see vertex a or
point a maps to point and on this
congruent triangle vertex B
Maps to point em and so you can say look
a B the length of a B is congruent to nm
so it all matches up and we can say that
these two are congruent by angle angle
side by a AAS so we did this one is this
one right over here is congruent to this
one right over there now let's look at
these two characters so here we have an
angle forty degrees aside in between and
then another angle so it looks like a si
is going to be involved we look at this
one right over here we have a forty
degrees 40 degrees seven and then 60 you
might say wait here the forty degrees is
on the bottom then here it's on the top
but remember things can be congruent if
you can flip them if you can flip them
rotate them shift them whatever so if
you flip this guy over you will get this
one over here and that would not have
happened if you had flipped this one to
get this one over here so you see these
two by you have let me just make it
clear you have the 60 degree angle is
congruent to this 60 degree angle you
have the side of length seven is
congruent to this side of length seven
and then you have the 40 degree angle is
congruent to this forty degree angle so
once again these two characters are
congruent to each other and we can write
I'll write it where I have some I'll
write right over here we can say
triangle d EF triangle d EF is congruent
to triangle and here we have to be
careful again D Point D is the vertex
for the 60 degree side so I'm going to
start at H which is the vertex of the 60
degree side over here is congruent to
triangle H and we went from D to e e is
the vertex on the forty degree side kind
of the other vertex that shares the
seven length segment right over here so
we want to go from H to G a
gee I and we know that from
angle-side-angle by by angle-side-angle
so that gives us that that character
right over there is congruent to this
character right over here and then
finally we're left with this poor poor
chap and it looks like it is not
congruent to any of them it is tempting
to try to match it up to this one
especially because the angles here on
the bottom and you have the seven side
over here angles here on the bottom and
the seven side over here but it doesn't
match up because the order of the angles
aren't the same you don't have the same
corresponding angles if you try to do
this little exercise where you map
everything to each other you wouldn't be
able to do it right over here and this
over here you know it might have been a
trick question where maybe if you did
the math if this was like a forty or
sixty degree angle maybe then maybe you
could have you could have matched this
to some of the other triangles or maybe
even some of them to each other but this
last angle in all of these cases forty
plus 60 is is a hundred this is going to
be an eighty degree angle right over
they have to add up to 180 this is an
eighty degree angle this is an eighty
degree angle if this ended up by the
math being a forty or sixty degree angle
then it could have been a little bit
more interesting there might have been
other other other congruent pairs but
this is an eighty degree angle in every
case the other angle is 80 degrees so
this is just a loan unfortunately for
for him he is not able to find a a
congruent companion